hey folks I'm mark Normand here we are
in the streets of New York City Hey
delivery I'm working on my delivery too
buddy yes all the comedy clubs have
closed I'm climbing the walls I'm
hitting the streets to tell some jokes
about this pandemic a lot of these have
flew right over people's head all right
let's go tell some jokes
this is Corona comedy wanna hear some
corona jokes you know corona virus what
the hell why is it my white privilige
kicked in oh boy all right I got heckled
by the muck when the hell is my white
privilige gonna kick in ladies you guys
wanna hear any jokes about Corona Corona
beer sales have plummeted just because
of the name similarity which I don't get
cuz when AJ killed his wife I didn't
stop drinking orange juice I didn't stop
drinking orange juice although I may
find some clean material all jokes have
written hey the corona bat he's the new
aids monkey jokes to the people because
the clubs are closed and everybody needs
a good chuckle right ma'am
[Music]
you know I heard the cure for this thing
is eatin ass that's why old people are
all dying eating ass is the cure that's
why young people are staying strong so
in China the first dog has died of
coronavirus I know it's about time to
take it for a walk Kevin Durant got
tested positive for coronavirus you know
NBA star Magic Johnson said he'll be
fine Magic Johnson said he'll be fine
yeah thank God you guys are high I need
the people a the reaction yes
it's dying it's curious it's got to sell
drugs how about this to pick the
presidential candidate since they're all
elderly we got a guy with corona tack
off on all of them whoever lives wins
hey all right
one toilet paper minimum for the show
sir have a good day the first animal to
go extinct after all this gonna be the
social butterfly
[Music]
really were they Chinese ah
social butterfly we got affair thanks
I'll be here all week on this corner you
can venmo me at Kevin Hart thank you
I'll call you that's a good-looking
[ __ ] you know they say a coffee you can
get you can get infected from a cough
imagine what a queef can do imagine what
a queef can do imagine what a queef can
do a queef that's pretty uh it's
timeless hey free comedy much like
Amazon I'm working on my delivery okay a
dad he's a lot of touch
I said no more handshakes just fist me
just fist me well after that I
definitely got it here comes my ride
[Music]
I'm not dancing today finish everything